♪
PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN HAS A
SOLUTION TO AMERICANS GAS PRICES
BLAME EVERYONE BUT HIMSELF,
AFTER ORDERING THE RELEASE OF
1 MILLION BARRELS OF OIL PER DAY
FROM THE STRATEGIC RESERVE THE
PRESIDENT OBSESSING OVER
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
>> HIS WAR IS IMPOSING THE PACK
CRISIS AND DEMOCRACIES AROUND
THE WORLD.
THE START OF THIS YEAR -- WAS
ABOUT $3.30 A GALLON, TODAY IS
ABOUT AVERAGE FOR 20, 422.
THE REASON FOR THAT IT'S BECAUSE
OF VLADIMIR PUTIN'S WAR.
MANY CONTINUE TO USE EVERY TOOL
AT MY DISPOSAL TO PROTECT YOU
FROM THEIR PRICE HIKE.
IT'S NOT TIME FOR POLITICS.
>> Jeanine: WHEN HE WASN'T
PUSHING THE TALKING POINT THE
PRESIDENT WAS BUSY DEMONIZING
AMERICAN OIL COMPANIES.
>> BUT SOME COMPANIES HAVE BEEN
VERY BLUNT, THEY DON'T WANT TO
INCREASE SUPPLY BECAUSE LENDER
POLLUTANTS PRICE HIKES INC.
MAKES HIGHER PROFITS.
IT'S TIME TO STEP UP FOR THE
GOOD OF YOUR COUNTRY, THE GOOD
OF THE WORLD TO INVEST IN THE
MEDIA PRODUCTION THAT WE NEED TO
RESPOND TO VLADIMIR PUTIN.
>> Jeanine: THERE IS A HUGE
PROBLEM FOR PRESIDENT BIDEN.
THEY FAULT HIM AND AT LEAST 6%
BLAME RUSSIANS INVASION OF
UKRAINE.
ALL RIGHT, IT SEEMS AS THOUGH
THE AMERICANS REALLY UNDERSTAND
WHAT IS GOING ON HERE THAT
THEY'RE VERY INTUITIVE, THAT
JOE BIDEN CAN PUSH AS MUCH AS HE
WANTS, BUT IS AGAIN A WORK?
>> Greg: I THINK HE ASSUMES
THAT EVERYONE IS AS FORGETFUL AS
HE IS.
WE KNOW WHAT INFLATION WAS LIKE
BEFORE THE WAR, IT WAS SOARING.
SURE THE WAR DIDN'T HELP IT BUT
IT WAS ON ITS WAY UP, WAY BEFORE
VLADIMIR PUTIN WENT INTO
UKRAINE.
I THINK WHAT TICKS ME OFF ABOUT
THIS IS THE CONSTANT REFRAIN OF
THE VLADIMIR PUTIN THE PRICE
HIKE IT MEANS THAT THE
WHITE HOUSE IS MORE CONCERNED
AND SPENDS MORE TIME WITH
CREATING HANDY SLOGANS THAT
ACTUALLY HANDLING THE PROBLEM OF
INFLATION, THE NATURE OF
INFLATION DOESN'T REALLY AFFECT
THEM BECAUSE IT'S NOT A PROBLEM
WHEN YOU'RE IN POWER OR WEALTHY,
BUT THE MESSAGING IS WE TALKED
ABOUT --
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SAID THAT IT'S A MESSAGING
PROBLEM, THAT'S ALL IT IS.
IT'S EVERYTHING THAT YOU NEED TO
HEAR ABOUT THE LEFT IS THAT
NOTHING IS A PROBLEM UNTIL IT
HAS TO DO WITH YOUR POLITICAL
POWER.
INFLATION HURTS THE POOR BUT
IT'S A PROBLEM ONLY IF IT HELPS
BOTH.
IT'S ONLY REALLY A PROBLEM IF
THE ANACOSTIA ELECTION, SO ALL
OF THIS THAT YOU'RE SEEING RIGHT
NOW IS NOT ABOUT MORALITY, IT'S
ABOUT MESSAGING, AND THAT IS
DISGUSTING BECAUSE WE COULD.
IT'S ALL EVERYTHING, WE SHOULD
STOP TALK ABOUT POLITICS.
DUDE, YOU'RE THE ONLY ONE WHO'S
POLITICIZED THIS, NO ONE ELSE'S.
NOBODY CARES ABOUT THE
MESSAGING, THEY JUST WANT TO GET
THERE THEIR BREAD AND MILK DOWN.
>> Jeanine: THEY DON'T GET
THAT TAX HIKE WHICH BASICALLY IS
INFLATION.
DO THEY HAVE TIME TO TURN ITS
AROMA FOR THE MIDTERMS?
>> Dana: I KNOW YOU LIKE
THOSE, WHEN YOU HEAR THAT THERE
IS A PROBLEM ANYWHERE WITH A
COMPANY OR AT THE WHITE HOUSE OR
WHEREVER IT MIGHT BE, 99% OF THE
TIME IT IS NOT, IT'S VERY
FRUSTRATING TO THE COMMUNICATORS
BECAUSE IF YOU GET THE FACTS AS
BETTER POLICIES YOU CAN FIX A
P.R. PROBLEM THAT'S HOW IT
WORKS.
JUST THIS WEEK PRESIDENT
JOE BIDEN CALLED FOR 11 NEW
TAXES ON AMERICAN ENERGY.
HIS PRICE HIKE, YOU CAN GET MORE
OF A PRICE HIKE AND PUTTING MORE
TAXES ON ENERGY AND GAS.
IT'S ANOTHER P.R. MOVE THAT WILL
ACTUALLY.
THE OTHER THING THAT BOTHERS ME
AND I LIKE TO ANALOGY.
>> Greg: PERMISSION GRANTED.
>> Dana: THE STRATEGIC
PETROLEUM PRESERVE HAVING IT,
AND THE WHITE HOUSE TRY TO SAY
THAT THAT'S AN ACCOMPLISHMENT.
THAT'S LIKE TRYING TO GET CREDIT
FOR PAYING OFF YOUR CREDIT CARD
BILL BY TAKING OUT A LOAN.
AND THERE'S NO PLAN TO REPLACE
IT, I'LL TELL YOU ONE OTHER
THING SINCE 2,020 THE
REPUBLICANS PUT FORWARD A PLAN
UNDER PRESIDENT TRUMP TO REFILL
THE STRATEGIC PETROLEUM RESERVE
BECAUSE GAS PRICES THEY WERE AT
BRECHER LOWE'S.
CHUCK SCHUMER THE DEMOCRATIC
LEADER AT THE TIME SAID HE WAS
PROUD TO BE THE ONE TO KILL IT.
OKAY, SO NOW THEY'RE ANNOUNCING
TO TAKE A MILLION BARRELS OUT WE
IS 25 MILLION, SORRY MORE THAN
THAT.
IT'S A DROP IN THE BUCKET,
THEY'VE ANNOUNCED NO PLANS TO
REFILL IT, IT SUPPOSED TO BE FOR
AN EMERGENCY.
>> Jeanine: WITH REGARD TO
THAT, THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT A
MILLION BARRELS A DAY WHICH
APPARENTLY IS
1.3 MILLION BARRELS BELOW WHAT
WE WERE WHEN DONALD TRUMP WAS IN
OFFICE AND IN NOVEMBER WE HAD
THE RESERVE AND THEN AGAIN IN
MARCH WE HAD THE RESERVE, GAS
PRICES WENT DOWN FOR A MINUTE
AND THEN THEY FLEW UP AGAIN WHAT
GOOD DOES IT DO?
>> Jesse: WHEN DONALD TRUMP
WANTED TO RESTOCK THE RESERVES
OIL WAS AT $24 A BARREL.
THAT WOULD'VE BEEN THE BEST TIME
TO RESTOCK THE STOCKPILE AND NOW
HE IS GOING TO SHED ABOUT A
THIRD OF THE STOCKPILE, HUNDRED
AND 80 MILLION TO
560 MILLION BARRELS ACYL STOCK.
WERE LETTING GO OF A THIRD OF IT
SOMEONE IS GONNA HAVE TO
REPLENISH THAT, IT'S NEVER GOING
BACK DOWN TO 20 FOR THE NEXT
COUPLE OF YEARS SOBER ENOUGH TO
PAY MORE MONEY.
THEY DID THIS BIG SPEECH, THIS A
WORK TO DO EVERYTHING WE CAN
HERE IN AMERICA TO DRILL
DOMESTICALLY.
THE VERY NEXT DAY, OIL PRICES ON
THE WORLD MARKET WENT DOWN $10,
IT WAS JUST ON THAT SPEECH, AND
THAT'S WHICH PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN
DOESN'T UNDERSTAND YOU TO SEND A
SIGNAL TO THE PRODUCERS IN THE
MARKET THAT WE ARE IN THERE FOR
THE LONG TERM.
JOE BIDEN SIGNAL TO OIL AND GAS
IS THAT WERE PUTTING OUT A
BUSINESS, AND THAT'S REALLY BAD
FOR BUSINESS.
THIS IS HOW STUPID JOE BIDEN IS
NOW THE WERE ON THAT SUBJECT YOU
CAN'T JUST HOP FROM LILY PAD TO
LILY PAD.
OH, WE HAVE AN ENERGY CRISIS.
THAT'S 1% OF THE CARS ON THE
ROAD THAT ARE ELECTRIC VEHICLES,
ONLY 12% OF OUR ENERGY
CONSUMPTION IS RENEWABLE, IT'S
NOT THAT EASY THAT YOU CAN JUST
FLIP IT OVER LIKE THAT.
HE NEEDS TO FIGURE THIS OUT
BECAUSE AS YOU POINTED OUT
EARLIER IN YOUR QUESTION, THIS
IS A $5,000 A YEAR TAX HIKE ON
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, NOT JUST
MAKING MINIMUM WAGE YOU'RE
GETTING HIT WITH A $5,000 A YEAR
TAX HIKE FROM JOE BIDEN.
>> Jeanine: ONE OF THE
PROBLEMS THAT I MISS YOU?
YEAH I KIND OF MISSED YOU.
I'M GLAD YOU'RE BACK I'M GLAD
THE VIEWERS ARE GLAD YOUR BACK
TOO.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE LEASE LANDS
THAT THEY HAVE, JOE BIDEN IS NOW
TALKING ABOUT PENALIZING PEOPLE
THAT HAVE LEASES ON SOME OF THE
OIL RESERVES BECAUSE HE SAYS
THEY DON'T DRILL FOR OIL ORGAN
TO PUNISH THEM.
>> Geraldo: USE IT OR LOSE IT
WHAT'S WRONG WITH THAT?
YOU BUILD THE ROAD WIDE GET THE
LEASE?
>> Jeanine: WHEN
PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN RAN FOR
OFFICE HE WANTED TO DESTROY THE
OIL AND GAS INDUSTRIES.
SO THEY HAVE TO GET PERMISSION.
>> Geraldo: I CAN SEE THAT
THIS IS THE VERY WORST TIME FOR
DEMOCRATS TO GO TO THEIR CLIMATE
ADVOCATES AND CUT DOWN ON THE
PRODUCTION OF HYDROCARBON,
TIMING IS EVERYTHING IN LIFE AND
IN POLITICS.
I THINK I CAN SEE THAT.
ALSO I HAVE A RULE THAT THE
HIGHER THE PRICE OF GAS, THE
LOWER THE POPULARITY OF THE
PRESIDENT, THERE'S AN INVERSE
RELATIONSHIP AND NOW YOU ARE
SEEING THE PRICE OF GAS GOING
UP, THE PRESIDENT'S POPULARITY
IS SINKING.
IN TERMS OF WHAT IS GOING ON
WITH ENERGY, YOU REALLY NEED NOW
TO UNDERSTAND THE STRATEGIC
PETROLEUM RESERVE.
THERE IS 1.4 BILLION BARRELS
JUST IN THE PART THAT THE
GOVERNMENT CONTROLS, PLUS
ANOTHER 3 BILLION BARRELS AND
THERE THE PRIVATE SECTOR
CONTROLS.
SO WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT 1 MILLIOR
HUNDRED AND 80 DAYS, THAT'S A
DROP IN THE BUCKET OUT OF THE
STRATEGIC RESERVE, WHAT THEY'RE
TRYING TO DO IS THE GET THE OIL
TRADERS SO THEY STOP SPECULATING
BECAUSE OF THEIR SPECULATION I
MAINTAIN EVEN THOUGH THE OIL
INDUSTRY GETS A FREE RIDE, I
MAINTAIN THAT THEY ARE
MANIPULATING THE PRICE, THEY ARE
TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF THE SITUATION
RIGHT NOW.
AND THEY ARE EXACERBATING IT TO
MAKE THE OIL COMPANIES THE
VICTIMS IS ABSURD.
>> Jesse